If you
were kidnaped and forced to play a deadly game
where only the most ruthless people survive.
What would you do?
An entire island
full of killers is out to get you,
and you'll have to use your game
or knowledge to escape in one piece.
I'm here to break down the mistakes
made, what you should do,
and how to beat the bomb game in a BTOOOM!
This teenager's dreams of being the best in
the world is going to end up costing him his life.
Sakamoto here is one of the best gamers
in the whole of Japan.
He plays the video game BTOOOM!
A third person shooter with bombs
as the primary means of attack,
as well as sonar to find enemies around the map.
He takes everyone out with ease,
like the armchair warrior
that he is and figures that he needs
to test his skills on a world wide scale.
However, in the real world, a Sakamoto is a loser
and has no life one day he wakes up in a forest
and is confused how he got there.
The night before, he was playing bottom
as usual and has no memory of leaving his house.
He opens his phone to find out
that he has no service.
That's when he looks at his hand
and finds a glass short embedded inside,
noticing a bag on the ground.
He opens it to find his wallet
and the items he bought from the convenience store
the night before.
Sakamoto makes his way through the forest
and onto a beach front.
Suddenly,
he now realizes that he's a long way from home.
He sits down on the beach
and finds a strange looking item in his bag
with a timer throwing it before it hits zero.
The item turns out to be a bomb,
just like in his video game.
At night.
He notices another person off in the distance.
He waves to the stranger when suddenly
the silhouette comes rushing towards him
with killer intent.
Sakamoto realizes that the man looks exactly
like an enemy in BTOOOM!
and runs off. OK, this is insane.
Because just like if you threw a call of duty
champion player into real life basic training,
it's pretty obvious that Sakamoto
will likely suck at anything physically tough
unless he's a gamer and a gym rat.
And based on what we saw, he isn't.
And based on this encounter
with these crazy bastards,
it means that it's pretty clear that we're somehow
stuck in a world just like our video game.
While we may not be physically up to par
with what horrors await us in this world,
we do have some advantages that we could use.
In a way, we've been training for this day
our entire lives
because Sakamoto is not just an avid
player of bottom whom he is a video game champion,
which means that he's the best of the best
at something to do with the bottom game.
Whether that's in his quick reaction times
that help him in catching danger when it shows up,
or if it's in his planning and strategies
when it comes to planning out attacks
or defending himself and his teammates.
And one thing is for sure
is that all of his training in video games
means that his cognitive abilities,
such as spatial navigation,
reasoning, memory and perception must be superior,
at least to a degree, and means that this,
at the very least,
could give him an edge and his problem
solving skills
and in what he's about to face in this world.
But even before he met that guy, waking up on
what looks to be a deserted jungle island
means that he should have been way more cautious.
He even found that bottle of green tea
and some food,
but went through it
all like there was no tomorrow.
What he should have done was to minimize
his consumption, to make his supplies last longer.
He even wasted a perfectly good parachute,
which you can use for so many things, for one.
You can use the canopy,
which is the large portion of the parachute.
It's made from nylon,
and it makes a great waterproof, lightweight
tent or a bedroll or heck even fishing lines
or possibly even a poncho to wear.
And this is not even taking into account
the suspension lines
that connects the harness to the canopy, which
also could have been used for countless things.
These para courts can usually carry around up
to £550 easily and could be used as towed lines
or to be able to climb trees or scale walls
thanks to its high tensile strength.
But somehow, despite Sakamoto
being the top G in the video game
world, is proving to be rather lame in real life.
Unless he stops acting like such an idiot, he's
not going to survive much longer.
The man continues
chasing him, and this gamer realizes
that he needs to fight back or he's going to die.
Recalling his BTOOM! Expertize.
Sakamoto hides from the man
and ambushes him, interrogating him on
what the hell is really going on.
The man laughs in his face and throws a grenade,
injuring Sakamoto and forcing him to run away.
He surrenders, but is attacked again
and thrown off of the cliff face.
That's when the glass shard begins to glow,
just like the sonar radar in battle.
Sakamoto realizes that participants
all have different types of grenades
and his habit to have a timer.
Unlike the man attacking him, he decides to run
past the enemy and jumps into the water.
The man laughs,
thinking that he has Sakamoto cornered.
Suddenly, Sakamoto is timer bombs
blow up and kill the man instantly, officially
turning this wannabe badass
into a stone cold killer for real.
And he's about to face
even deadlier challenges in the coming days.
Some time later, he finds a pretty girl bathing
in a waterfall, and Sakamoto chases after her.
He runs through the forest and finds a fat guy
taking a crap.
The fat guy
explains that a plane kidnaped them all
and took around 30 people to an uninhabited island
in the Pacific Ocean with no food or water.
He mentions that on the plane,
this guy, known as the Game Master, gave everybody
deadly bombs
and told them that the only way to leave
would be to gather seven ships
from the bodies of seven people.
And the only way to get these chips
would be to kill someone to get it.
The fat guy then asks to team up,
but Sakamoto knows he's hiding something.
The man asks to see his BIMS,
but Sakamoto realizes that he might just be
playing dumb and refuses to show him his bombs.
But agrees to team up.
OK, now we officially know for sure
that we're in some type of hellish reality
that has us at each other's necks,
just like our BTOOOM! video game.
And this means that the rules of the game apply
and that everybody is officially our enemy.
But in this case, until we're better equipped,
even if it's risky, it is likely to be beneficial
for us, at least temporarily.
Only if we team up. And while they could use us
as bait or screw us over.
This will also allow us to do the same.
Teaming up at this instance
means that we simply need to be on alert
because in actuality, just like in Mann's
earlier days, since the dawn of time, as time goes
on, it is likely that all of our competitors
here will form factions, a.k.a.
tribes, because we're social creatures by default,
which means teaming up with others
will give all the other players here
visceral comfort
from being in contact and fellowship with one
another and will allow us to defend against
other rival groups formed in an effort
to pick a winning side and survive,
at least to a degree, because saying in groups
will be to the benefit of everyone,
at least to a point.
This is what biologists call the use sociality,
which is the highest level of sociality
and defined by the division of labors
and responsibilities,
where members will perform altruistic acts
to help benefit the overall group as a whole.
If you put a group of people onto an island
and force them to kill each other,
it is likely that many will begin to form groups
whether we like it or not.
Think of us like ants in a colony because that's
just how humans are designed to act.
If we don't join this guy and start
forming our own tribe, others will anyways
until we're eventually outnumbered and outgunned.
In this instance,
the enemy of our enemy is our friend.
But I still wouldn't
trust this guy with showing him my bombs
because it's always good to have some tricks up
my sleeve.
We still don't know what's in store for us
They climb a nearby hill to see a helicopter
dropping off food rations
and head to one of the ration drop sites.
Sakamoto arrives to see this lady in the distance
who calls dibs than suddenly a bomb detonates
from below and blows her shit up.
Sunglasses man here picks the lady up
and takes her bombs and food before running away.
Shocked Sakamoto notices
another ration off in the distance
and the two decide to head over there.
On the way,
the two guys are shocked to see this crazy
looking kid named Kousuke next to a dead corpse.
Not only that the kid didn't pop up on the radar,
which makes Sakamoto realize that it only picks up
people who are moving.
The crew decides to run away,
but Kousuke is determined to find them
and kill them while running.
The fat guy trips like a chump
and sprains his ankle. Oh, boo hoo.
He tells Sakamoto to leave him behind,
but the kid decides to lure Kousuke away
and let the fat guy escape.
Sakamoto uses his sonar to figure out the boy's
location and realizes that he needs to run
towards him to escape his attack. OK,
this is insane.
And while what Sakamoto did was sweet as all
get out, it was so dumb
because he could have used this opportunity
to use the fat as bait and take down Kousuke.
Now I know what I said earlier
about forming tribes, but this was low key.
The real reason
why we kept the fat guy around to use him as bait.
Because, let's face it,
this guy is useless and served
no real purpose to us other than moral support
or as bait or a distraction.
Sakamoto should have made a lemonade
out of the situation and use the fat guy,
but instead he chose to have a heart Also,
we've seen how much of a glutton
this fat guy is from the start,
and we're in a survival situation.
Keeping him around to a degree
is smart in the long term.
This guy will finish our supplies if we let him.
If anything,
I would have tried to get the best of both worlds
and would have used the fat guy's bait but
kill Kousuke before he got onto our fat friend.
This way
we could have still used him in some instances.
Of scavenging for drop points for supplies,
because after seeing that lady get blown to all
hell, he'll honestly
serve a really significant purpose.
So using him as a meat shield
for us to get more supplies,
suddenly they cross each other's paths
and Kousuke tosses a big fatty as they land.
Sakamoto then realizes that this boy
is a high level platoon player
and he continues evading cost until the crazy kid
throws an implosion bomb which lands on his bag.
Suddenly, Sakamoto quickly
throws the bag into the air as it turns into dust
The kid baits Sakamoto into revealing his location
and throws another grenade his way injured.
He walks out of hiding in a daze
and looks to the sky.
Kousuke finds him and throws
one more grenade to finish the job.
But that's when Sakamoto whips out a bag
that swallows the grenade hole.
He runs off and out of the crazy kid's sight,
ambushing him from behind with a timer grenade
The kid tries using the sonar to find him,
but realizes that Sakamoto is
canceling it out
by activating his sonar at the exact same time.
He catches guard off guard and hits him
with the grenade, severely injuring the young kid.
Some time later,
they spot a body floating in a nearby waterfall.
The man is dead and has no pants.
Sakamoto gets ready to leave
in case of an enemy attack,
but the fat guy tells him
that his leg is still injured and can't walk.
Sakamoto decides
to check out what's going on above the waterfall
and finds another corpse in the forest.
He decides to use his sonar to get a hint of where
the enemy could be and spots this pretty lady
from before standing on top of a cliff.
Suddenly, she throws a grenade off
in the wrong direction. But Sakamoto quickly
realizes that this is a corrosive gas grenade,
meaning it's incredibly toxic.
OK, this is really, really bad.
This weapon is BTOOOM!
classic and produces
a cloud of highly corrosive gas,
which literally disintegrates
organic matter in seconds.
This basically means
that this thing will melt the weed skin
right off of you and has a lethal radius
of between 50 to 100 meters.
Which means that even if this girl threw
the grenade in the wrong direction,
they need to get out of there now
because that shit will still reach them.
And while Sakamoto could likely overpower
this girl one on one, she's packin,
which means that he needs to keep his guard up
and try to outsmart her until he can disarm her.
Now, this situation has proven to us that
we can't kill this girl yet, because in actuality,
we need her.
Our fat he made is already proving
to be way more trouble than he's worth.
And with his leg still injured, he's not even good
enough to use as bait since he can't even move.
This means that we're officially hiring,
and this girl is the perfect candidate
that we could use for our business.
And speaking of business,
this grenade is one that we still have yet
to get our fat, greasy paws on.
And if she refuses to join us,
we could just kill her and steal her grenade stash
To make finding more of these class of grenades.
My number one priority from here on out.
Sakamoto runs from the gas and finds himself
staring the girl right in the face.
He tries to calm her down
by asking her to team up,
but she freaks out and throws a grenade at him.
He manages to run through the cloud of smoke
and swipes her grenade,
but she knocks him over with a stun gun.
However, Sakamoto do flips the stun gun
back onto her, knocking her out that night turned
the two guys share a meal together,
and they explain to her that they're
trustworthy people.
She tells them that there's no point of even
beating the death game
since someone close to them in
the real world is responsible for their kidnaping.
That's when they realize they've been abandoned
by their friends and family,
but they're interrupted
when they hear something in the forest.
Suddenly, giant lizards appear from the shadows.
The crew try fetching their stolen bombs,
but soon find out that the bombs Kousuke gave them
aren't working suddenly someone throws a bomb
onto the fat guy's leg and badly injures it.
They continue making their way through the swamp
when suddenly the Komodo dragons reappear
and attack them.
Sakamoto loses sight of the fat
guy, ending up in a secluded part of the forest
with absolutely no supplies.
He realizes that the fat guy may have just ditched
him and screams out in anger That's
when the Komodo dragon attacks again, and a bomb
comes up out of nowhere with the fat guy
showing up to save the day.
The continue through the forest, feeling the sea
breeze and getting closer to their destiny.
The crew finds themselves at a ladder and use
a bit of teamwork to bring the girl up with them.
However, the ladder breaks under their weight
and they hear the Komodo dragons coming back.
Oh, now we have Komodo dragons chasing us. Great.
This reminds me whenever I hear Dom
whining about playing Far Cry three
because just like those damn lizard bastard
on vases, Rook Island,
these komodo dragons are no joke.
These things can grow to be over three meters
long and possess
razor sharp teeth and a poisonous saliva
that can kill a person within hours after a bite.
These guys are so badass that they legit
have no natural predators in their native habitat,
which means that these guys
are at the top of their food chain.
These things move quicker than our a.k.a. Bobcat,
as we call them.
These things usually pick their prey apart
when it's solo
and not in a group,
but with an army of lizards like these.
After three humans makes me think that these guys
are way hungrier for food than us.
Now, one of the most effective things we could do
is to run away and keep running.
Since attacking it head on with just
our fists is a big, fat No-No,
and we don't want to waste our bombs.
And the fact that these things are capable
of only short bursts of explosive energy
up to 21 kilometers per hour, meaning
running away from them in a zigzag pattern will be
one of the best moves to escape these things.
Because these things can really only run
in a straight like pattern.
And utilizing
the trees around us while seemingly safe
is the exact opposite of where we want to go.
Because while older commandos can't really climb
such things, well, young dragons may be nesting
within the trees now,
because these dragons have followed us
so far makes me think that something
is driving them to us.
Because naturally, Komodo dragons only attack
if they are threatened or provoked or smell blood.
And this last part is
where I think we have a serious problem
because our friend over here is a drippin
attraction for these bloodsucking bastards.
And he is the reason most likely
that these things are continuing to follow us.
This means that we need to put an end to this now
and give the people or this lizard
what they want.
This dude right here,
because to them he's looking like a sick snack.
If I was Sakamoto, I grab a nice rock and smash
this guy's skull and leaving him to the lizards
while we find a way up this rusty piece of ladder
because, let's be
honest, were outnumbered, outgunned.
And our only two teammates are this dude
and this chick.
And this dude's leg is not getting fixed
any time soon, at least not by us.
And while we could use this guy's strength,
his injury makes him a liability.
And also, let's be honest,
if you were a rambunctious teenager, gamer, nerd,
and national champion,
who would you really want to save?
Don't lie.
Sakamoto climbs up a ladder, making the fat
guy thinks that he's leaving the unconscious girl
for dead acting quickly.
Sakamoto throws
a corrosive gas grenade at the dragon's location.
The fat guy is confused
by how he managed to use the girl's bombs.
But Sakamoto says that he used the girl's fingers
to touch the button.
He tells them that they're safe
from the corrosive gas
as well because of the sea breeze that morning.
They all wake up safe and sound.
But something is wrong with fat guy.
Suddenly, he passes out while crying out in pain
from his injured leg.
They fetch some medicine for the man
pouring it on to his leg,
causing him to pass out again from the shock.
Later, Sakamoto confronts
the mysterious girl about how she's managed
to retrieve all of her supplies
He knows that she's killed a lot of people
and would only need to kill him and fat guy
to gather the right amount of shards
to leave the island.
Suddenly they feel someone used the sonar
and the girl tells him that she'll leave the crew
to go her own way.
Sakamoto tells her to not to leave and insists
that he'll act as a decoy to fight
the incoming enemy. My, how nice of him.
He goes to the forest and scans to find out
if the enemy is near.
That's when the mystery man attacks,
forcing Sakamoto to run off the cliff side.
He tries convincing the bandana man
to join his crew, but a timer bomb lands
next to him and catches Sakamoto off guard.
The men hold him hostage,
but Sakamoto manages to taser Mr.
Overalls here and runs away.
He goes back to the hideout,
but Bandana Man here follows and demands
that they hand back his supplies.
The fat guy tries attacking him from behind,
but gets his fingers chopped off in the process.
Sakamoto rushes towards him, but bandana man
easily kicks him off of the building
when he climbs back up.
He sees the fat guy writhing about in pain,
and the pretty girl is nowhere to be found.
Noticing her phone on the ground,
he takes a look at her wallpaper and notices
a costly similar to his virtual wife.
In battle, Himiko Sakamoto finds himself
outside of the enemy hideout and bandana.
Man knows exactly where he's going to enter.
He hide behind a door and springs out to see Mr.
Overalls and step on the roof.
Sakamoto makes his entrance
and sneaks into the building.
He opens this door, which is concealing a hidden
bomb and manages to catch it, turning it off
and saving himself from certain death.
OK, we all just saw how easy it was for Bandana
Man to take us out this military style trap.
Just prove to us how prepared our enemy is.
However, we know a BAM
bomb becomes the property of whoever disables it,
and we've only got one shot to use it.
Finding the girl with our radar
shouldn't be too much of an issue.
However, dealing with bandana man is the problem,
because even if we escape, we won't get very far.
But in every played of armor,
there is always a chink that we could exploit.
And his is Mr. Overalls.
I would work on taking him out
since he is the easiest to handle.
Subduing Mr.
Overalls will give us access to his bare bombs.
I would knock him out and tie him up
using the shoelaces in our shoes.
I then use his hands to give us access
to his bombs if that plan doesn't work.
Once he wakes up, I threaten him, saying we'll
slice off one digit off of his finger
and keep going until we reach the knuckle by using
the makeshift knife that we made beforehand
from the broken glass
and those windows from earlier.
I tell him that I will keep going on
to each finger until he's willing to cooperate.
I would force him to transfer
ownership of his bombs to us by making him
activate his bombs one at a time and setting them
with the a maximum of time
till the bomb goes off doing this for each one.
I would then manually disarm each one before the
countdown expires, allowing me to take control.
And this process would take a few minutes.
Since this could take a bit,
I would subdue him near a room
with only one exit facing opposite of us,
and perhaps a window facing outward with a ledge
to grab on to on the outskirts of that ledge
should we need to escape.
This will provide us with one entrance
to pay attention to while we get a hold of Mr.
Overalls Bombs.
Should Mr.
Bandana man show up midway
and having access to the windows
as a means of escape is super necessary
in case shit hits the fan.
And once we have all of Mr.
Overalls bombs, we'll have an edge.
But I'm not going near
Bandana man in close quarters.
Once we have more than enough EMS,
we'll be able to take out Bandana Man with ease.
Walking inside the room,
he finds the girl tied up on a bed
Sakamoto freezer and asks if she happened
to play the character of Himiko in Batum.
She says no, but Sakamoto decides
to call her by the name anyway.
Meanwhile, the bad guy realizes that their hostage
has just been taken away.
Mr. Overalls runs after them,
seeing glimpses of Sakamoto trying to escape.
Suddenly, the bad guy runs into a trap
set up by Sakamoto.
But Bandana man here has Himiko in his grip.
Bandana Man challenges Sakamoto to a fistfight,
but he's not interested.
Sakamoto runs out of cover,
grabbing a knife, trying to stab the man.
He's pushed away,
and the man pins him to the ground.
Himiko jumps on him, but is instantly thrown off.
That's when Bandanna.
Mann realizes that she's triggered
a gas bomb attached to his chest.
The two run off and climb out of the building,
leaving Bandanna Man for dead.
That night, they decide to rest up in the enemy's
hideout before meeting up with the fat guy.
When they're sleeping, he Mieko notices
a ghostlike figure staring at her.
She freaks out
and is certain that it wasn't her imagination.
Sakamoto takes her to look for the ghost
and finds a strange room that looks lived in.
Suddenly,
a hatchet wielding woman attacks him from behind
but Sakamoto knocks her out
and realizes that she's missing an arm.
When the ghost lady wakes up.
She tells Himiko here to not trust men.
But she tells that Sakamoto is different The ghost
lady explains that she was a nurse in her past
life and tampered with some medical records
to protect an unlawful doctor.
However, the doctor betrayed her
and put the blame onto the ghost lady.
She continues by saying that both her
and the doctor were sent to the island,
making it to the very end of the game together.
When the time came to leave,
the doctor betrayed her one final time blowing off
her arm and leaving the ghost lady for dead.
She tells them that once
someone gathers the right amount of shards,
a helicopter lands and takes them away to safety.
Sakamoto and her amico discuss
outside the possibility
of hijacking one when this happens,
but Himiko here is hiding a very important detail.
OK, this ghost lady is batshit crazy
and looks the part to back it up.
But she just told us a valuable piece of info.
Probably the most important thing
that we've ever received
because we already knew that we needed
a certain amount of crystals to leave the island.
But now we know the exact method
by which they'll rescue us.
And with this we can use it to prepare ourselves
for when we get rescued.
The island seems to have characteristics
of what is known as an oceanic island, a.k.a.
a volcanic island.
This type of island is formed
by eruptions of volcanoes
on the ocean floor, and this island's
flora consists of thousands of tropical trees.
And that means that there is enough cover
for us to be able to spot a helicopter approaching
without us being spotted.
However, at this point, we don't know for sure
if the metric by which the Game Master decides
who is to be rescued is solely based on the bio
indicators placed within our bodies,
or if that is supplemented by surveillance
scattered throughout the island
because it is very likely
that there are cameras placed everywhere,
which means that we won't be able to do
anything suspicious yet to outsmart them.
For now, we should continue our mission
with killing enough people to warrant the game
master sending a rescue helicopter.
However, knowing this, I would have the gang
prepare for when that time comes.
As of now,
it seems highly inefficient that the only way
this game rescues its members is by helicopter.
Because who's to say that would stop other members
from trying to take advantage of this
and perhaps even trying to ambush the helicopter
when it arrives?
I would try and make a ghost lady recall
every small detail of her story, first
noting what gear and security detail
that the helicopter had on them when they arrived,
including any weapons, as well as the location
of where it landed when it came to rescue them,
whether that was in the exact location of where
they were or nearby at a certain drop point,
more favorable to a landing helicopter,
because these details will matter
and will allow us to better prepare
for when we have enough crystals
to warrant a rescue team coming for us.
And knowing how to prepare for
it will allow us to figure out
a way to take advantage of it
when they arrive back at the old hideout.
They find that
the fat guy is being treated by mystery man.
He tells them that he's a doctor and that
he doesn't want to take part in the death game.
Sakamoto checks his bombs and sees
that he's not even used it even once.
They forgive him for being suspicious
and agree to work together.
Yeah, great move.
That's when they notice a supply drop nearby
and head out to go fetch supplies.
Sakamoto runs towards it
and runs into sunglasses guy.
Once again, they throw bombs at each other,
and Sakamoto is injured in the blast.
He notices sunglasses.
Guy throws a corrosive gas grenade at the doctor
and tells him to run.
Sakamoto manages to catch the trunk of food and
runs away before being trapped by a flame bomb.
Sunglasses guy tackles him and takes the truck
before Sakamoto is blown off of the cliff
and into the ocean.
He swims behind a rock, noticing
another shady man coming out of the forest.
The man finds the trunk of food
and goes over to steal it.
Suddenly,
a grenade activates and kills him on the spot.
Sunglasses guy takes the trunk,
but Sakamoto surprises him from behind,
threatening to blow him up The guy surrenders,
putting all of his belongings onto the ground.
Sakamoto knows this guy is bluffing,
but he doesn't know what he's up to
and tells him to turn around. But he doesn't.
But Sakamoto thinks his buddies are close by
and ignores this when he walks over to the trunk.
Sunglasses, Guy activates a remote bomb.
However, Sakamoto manages to avoid being blown up.
OK, it's one thing to not know
what someone is capable of in a place like this,
but this kid clearly knew
what sunglasses guy was capable of.
Since he literally saw him do some crazy shit
before sunglasses Guy isn't your average player.
He is cunning
and is prone to using traps to get his way.
As we saw earlier, Sakamoto had no excuses
and should not have rushed to get his loot.
This almost cost him his life,
and having him back away from his loot by itself
was not enough to ensure that he didn't have any
dirty tricks up his sleeve.
Sakamoto could have been a little less stupid
and at the very least could have ordered
sunglasses guy to turn around and give us a spin.
Seriously, this would have taken 2 seconds,
and judging from the fact
that the detonator was in this guy's mouth means
that this was a rookie mistake on Sakamoto part,
especially since sunglasses guy ignored Sakamoto
when he told him to turn around.
Which I don't know about you,
but that would be a major red flag Sunglasses guy
walks off into the forest and Koseki reappears,
telling him that he took all of the supplies
and the whole thing was a failure.
Back at the hideout, they try feeding the fat guy
whatever food they have left.
But the doctor mentions that they need to get rid
of the lizard poison within him, or he'll die.
Sakamoto and Himiko
tell the doc that they know a spa
to find a medicine where Ghost's Lady was staying.
And once there,
the doctor finds and fills a trunk full
of medical goodies, giving it to Sakamoto to keep.
But just then he
Mikko comes running and telling him that there's
a bomb inside that trunk right before it goes off.
This doc is a full on baddie
and threatens to kill him.
But that's when Ghost Lady appears and stabs him.
She then takes him a cold way,
and they find out that the doc has planted bombs
all over the building.
Just then the doc comes back injured as hell,
and she throws a bomb at him,
but not before he activates another bomb
that flings her off of the building.
He goes back inside to take out Himachal
when a grenade he throws bounces off of her boobs.
Suddenly, Sakamoto comes back from the dead
and chases him down.
And then he activates another remote bomb
and accidentally inches himself
and falls to the ground.
The ghost,
a lady tells the young, wants to step aside,
but she doesn't have the guts to finish the job.
With the medicine acquired and the older
couple reunited under strange circumstances.
Sakamoto and Himachal decide
to go back to the old hideout.
That's when he hears something strange.
At the distance, a homing bomb suddenly
chases him around, brutally injuring his leg.
The two instantly realize that the fat guy
has finally betrayed them.
They hear another homing bomb come their way
and Himiko grabs it, turning it off
before it explodes.
They try to chase him down,
but the fat guy thinks they're out for revenge.
Sakamoto screams out that he wants to apologize,
but that's when the fat guy is cornered
by a group of lizards, decides
to detonate the bomb on itself
to take out the reptile's
leaving Sakamoto and Himachal all by themselves.
That night, Himiko tells him to kill her.
If he does, he'll have enough shards
to beat the game and leave the island
but suck up motor refuses like the horned up.
Good boy that he is telling her
that he'll only leave the island
once they both have enough shards
ending this adventure.
Just like the film Predators
With that, no closer to getting home and more shit
about to head their way.
How do you do everybody? Griffin
here from How to Be Em?
What did you think about Platoon?
What did you like about it?
What you didn't like about it? Let us know. Don't
forget to like, comment. Subscribe.
And as always, don't
forget to check out our How to Be playlist.